nous partons maintenant comme promis
dans les titres pour les jardins du
louvre nous allons découvrir la mode du
prêt-à-porter féminin 83,84 celle qui
vous concerne directement mesdames et
puis aussi messieurs pas parfois carnet
de chèques interposés france roche et
patrice du terme
la mode parce que nous avons un petit
problème de son mais je pense que nous
allons rejoindre qu'on se mobilise
depuis lundi dernier et jusqu'à samedi
prochain des collections quelle
collection est bien celle de la chambre
syndicale des créateurs de mode d'une
part celle de la fédération française du
prêt à porter alors quelle est la
différence
il ya dix ans rue monk eux on ne veut
pas mélanger les torchons et les
serviettes puisque nous sommes dans un
milieu raffinés on ne peut pas mélanger
la pure laine vierge et le tissu
synthétique
vous allez voir tout de suite la
collection de claude montana qui est
créateur de mode dont les dernières
collections étaient très remontés et qui
va commencer à décider dans la salle
sully
j'entends une friture
nous sommes ici dans ce qu'on appelle la
cabine et qui est plutôt comme un hangar
où chantal thomass entreposer ses robes
et fait attendre ses mannequins pour le
défilé de cet après midi tandis que dans
la cabine d'un côté claude montana dont
vous venez de voir les aviatrices est en
train de se faire féliciter car sa
collection a remporté un très grand
succès alors où en sommes-nous au bout
d'une semaine de défilés bien je crois
qu'il y a deux sortes de mode
il y a d'abord la mode qu'on peut dire
quotidienne celle qui appartient à la
tradition classique du vêtement c'est à
dire le vêtement de sport le vêtement de
fait en tout cas un vêtement qui peut se
porter partout et puis il y a aussi le
vêtement le prêt à porter que
j'appellerais presque un portable
il s'agit de grands opéras de chiffons
ou certains créateurs expriment leur
attitude devant le monde actuel où
peut-être quelques pas leurs angoisses
en tout cas vous allez voir la
collection du couturier japonais
implantés à paris yamamoto et je vous
conseille de ne pas solliciter un emploi
habillé avec un de ses vêtements qui en
général pourtant et est assez beau et
très original vous allez voir la
collection yamamoto
mendiante vagabonde évadé de prison
prêtresse d'un culte maudit naufragés
d'une planète en ruines
les voici nous et les gangs de demain
vêtus de chapeaux claque écrasée de sacs
de couchage reconverti de couverture
retaillés elle arbore le cas qu'ils bleu
le gris d'uniformes de volée aux soldats
vulgaire perdu les rues de capotes trop
grande pour elle de géant qu'elle aurait
tué et peut être dévorés ces vampires
elles font leur fait d'emballage de
plastique aux couleurs fluo d'affiche
décoller sur des terrains vagues
ces rescapés de l'an 2000 ne montrent
pas leur corps rien de serre et le
coquet d'ajuster au de frivole elle aime
le rideau de deuil couvert de sable de
terre voire deux si elle se pare de
gants de métal de besace du cheminot le
pull-over cousue à placer leurs visages
et maquillés panini joues creuses lèvres
bleues leurs cheveux sont mouillés par
la tempête où la fièvre les coutures
sont effrangé et les boutons dépareillés
et même les mariés ressemblent à des
accidentés de ski qui pour épouser leur
chirurgien ont rapporté en guise de
voile la gaz de l'eure pansements et la
mousse de leur futur mari
alors maintenant claude montana vous
avez fait une collection extrêmement
féministe parce que nous avons vivo
aviatrice mais vous avez aussi les
banquières de wall street et les
académiciennes dont nous voyons un
exemple charmant qu'est ce qui vous a
donné l'idée de faire des robes
d'académicienne une marguerite yourcenar
n'est pas exactement taille mannequin
qu'est ce qui vous donne l'idée d'une
collection
choses et frais d'essence et
moi je ne fais rien
des voyages
alors vous voyagez vous voyez quelque
chose qu'il vous plaît vous l'absorber
ou photographier
restituer comment photographier par
simplement j'essaie de m'en souvenir
et en transposant bâtiment voilà
et si vous vous trouvez de temps en
temps un peu sec est un peu un peu à
cours d'idées qu'est ce que vous faites
il a rien à faire il faut attendre
et alors on arrive à la fin
ça vient ça vient pas mais se détache
weedon en mai
ça vient qu'est ce qui lie à la cour du
louvre
des acheteurs déjà ma liste des élèves
de cours de guti la presse
internationale proche
oui je voudrais poser une question à
monsieur montana ou à vous même là est
ce que là
haute couture sert encore de comment
dirais-je d'exemple au prêt à porter ou
est-ce que le prêt-à-porter aujourd'hui
est venu tout seul sans s'occuper de la
haute couture
en ce qui me concerne qu'est ce qui vous
a fait penser qu est-ce qui vous après
parce que feriez plutôt de ne pas porter
seulement parce que c'est un choix
non simplement je pense que si j'étais
né vingt ans plus tôt j'aurais pas lire
une culture et maintenant c'est une
chose inconcevable de parville le faire
vous disiez tout à l'heure ce cap
surtout des acheteurs et des
journalistes moi j'ai été tout à fait
étonné de voir un certain nombre de
personnages qui se promène dans la cour
du louvre et qui à eux seuls constituer
une collection
nous allons les regarder
d'art par an
alors vous voyez
le chapeau de pdg vous avez les lunettes
noires pourtant tu dis c'est déjà assez
original et puis vous avez les
personnages plus multicolores décidément
multicolores les coiffures régulièrement
sa fille et qui est ce qui se trouve
comme ça voulait dire
j'ai remarqué également une mode de la
class furent distillés bourhis fait par
la tempête
je m' a l'air de se répondre beaucoup ça
me concerne pas vraiment mon ami cas
sont à fait normalement elles dont le
cheveu tiré voilà
et ce style militaire quand même de
votre académicienne vous est venue comme
en mai à paris au sonar et c'est ça
c'est des aviatrices aussi ses
militaires en ce moment on dirait que
les créateurs sont très intéressés par
les capotes par les uniformes les deux
dépouilles d'univers qui n'auraient pas
encore eu lieu
vous parlez des actionnaires plutôt de
l'après guerre atomique
ah non ça
bien france roche on va vous quitter
maintenant puisque monsieur montana est
particulièrement discret sur son génie
on va laisser continuer d'inventer ses
modèles nous on va